want to give you some advice real quick
and I hope you don't take this
disrespectfully I think you should burn
whatever that book out why men love
but burn that on a bonfire and
read a book about divine feminine Etc
because I think you have a naturally
strong feminine energy but what's going
to happen is you're going to get used up
you're going to go to the club and give
all these feminine energies to guys who
go to the club every day and run a few
girls after you finish using the app
you're going to convince yourself that
men are trash men ain't and that
you need to change and you're going to
adapt more and more toxic behaviors
until at 28 none of no trace of the
woman the woman right here who says
she's a fixer exists because you've been
used up and disrespected for about five
six years so I would say work on your
strengths and develop that feminine
energy